giampà ciao a tutti speciale in cui con
la ruota andiamo a insegnargli fare cose
quindi vari giochi provare ad
addestrarlo un porta terra
vediamo come va e vediamo se questi
segnali che così io ho vitale perché mi
piace se volete vedere altri video
all'aperto
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn e
se iniziamo subito allora iniziano a
girare la ruota vediamo cosa mi capitò
di produrli dubbio a terra quindi il
comando che devo provare insegnarli è a
terra
noi abbiamo preparato i vari premi
vediamo se ci riesce allora è comparato
futuri premi
vediamo se sì allora innanzitutto lo
faccio a concentrare sul bis contino e
poi di capire che deve stare a terra
dopo busco 0
[Musica]
penso che ci vorrà un po di tempo per
insegnarle a terra
bravo bravo anche se lui non si è messo
a terra da solo
prima dobbiamo fargli capire che preme
da terra quindi dobbiamo aiutarlo
berlino si distrarrà tantissimo con il
gatto che dovete sapere che noi qui
abbiamo un paio di gatti non sono nostri
sono divisivi probabilmente però gli
stiamo dando da mangiare di tanto in
tanto e merlino sta cominciando a fare
amicizia anche se non è proprio un
amicizia semplice ecco che arriva che
questo gattone bellissimo è tutto nero e
c'è la puntata la codeina bianca
[Musica]
era che bravo però si siede di giovino
saluto va mica così abbiamo un po cosa
rapita vitale rigira ma berlino gli devi
insegnare fermo il che è molto difficile
devi provare a farlo stare fermo quindi
a non seguirci
e molto importante fare di tutti un
segno con la mano quindi tipo così di
stop
[Risate]
devo dire che mario è già bravo in
questo senso perché sta già fermo
allora voglio vedere che la crocchetta e
allontanati diglielo però fermo fermo
[Musica]
bravo mamertino cosa da fare è seduto
adesso fermo fermo perché bravo li
abbiamo già insegnato a stare seduto e
devo dire che sa già fare anche di stare
fermo quindi questo è stato un successo
ma è stato più facile per me tocca a me
tocca me adesso vediamo che mi capita
che facilissimo frattempo berlino
scappavo capo gatto berio berlino
parlate come gli dalla zampa al gas
berlino dalla zampa gatto tra capito
in tutto questo quello più perplesso il
gatto che sta lì e dice ma che stanno a
fa quindi sarà molto difficile
ho ottenuto riproviamo zappa già
[Musica]
interessate larghetto diceva votato ad
obama ma io conclude è già uscito bravo
cagnolone che ho detto adesso arriva il
gatto da dietro di dalla zampa di ho
capito io figura
che bravo cagnolone bravo è bravo però
sono contento anche come stato rapito
capitale gira la ruota vediamo chi ha
questo è molto difficile sia bravo bravo
[Risate]
e poi prova senza croccantino proviamo
gira gira gira gira gira gira
berlino diciamo che si chiamino provano
a farti dare to la zampa
[Applauso]
ha imparato e ha pure ricordato fitto
fitto
ok vediamo che mi capita benissimo in
campo invece si avvicina sempre di più
si rigira lasciamo la scelta vigato
mangia cibo anche gira vieni dobbiamo
insegnarli a venire
quando lo chiamiamo adesso stanno usando
il cazzo quindi funziona berlino vieni
vieni berlino berlino ieri è difficile
con una distrazione ieri vieni vieni
seduto seduto bravo
ok ragazzi ultimo turno vediamo qual è
l'ultima cosa che dovremmo provare ad
insegnarti mettiamo riporta giorno con
la pallina ma non mi porta mai le cose
quindi proviamo con i premi in questi a
picco a riportarle eco bike week di
berlino ora che lo lanciò ma che io
woman e web
io provo con vieni che buono
un altro che riportare io volo maggio
tutto questo allora prova a rilanciare
lo critica che porto io lo magno
[Musica]
rimane un altro premio premio presi lo
prendi lo splendido ma che berlino
lascio tutti i primi che
partiamo bardino programma berlino
quando l'erba no sì sto mangiando
frisbee maria di loreto nascondi hai
detto nascondino qua
hai detto nascondino con perché gatto
sta arrivando ma non ci credo
berlino gattino di cazzo tetto capito
perfino io gode mi riportava lo porto io
guarda che sono le crocchette al gatto
lega mentre la periodo il nostro trend
per oggi noi ci siamo divertiti partito
si mantenne che berlino ha imparato un
po di coda
non vediamo l'ora di praticarle un po
[Musica]
[Applauso]
tantissimo spero che anche voi vi siate
divertiti dunque lei che se volete
vedere altri video del genere mi piace
pure nei commenti che altri video volete
vedere ed ora milazzo fa 4 castellini si
può cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
cliccate su quello che preferite
ciao ciao sono settori 18 c inverno ciao
a tutti